I gave a copy of that book to a friend
of mine in New York who gave a copy to a
friend of hers who was part of that
despicable poultry minority of mankind
who had never heard of me and when she
gave the book back to my friend she said
is he gay and my friend said no she said
um is he English well it was I felt term
characteristic of the delightfully
informal nature of American society that
I should receive a letter from Yale
inviting me to deliver some tarry
pictures I mean I had of course been
long accustomed to the instant firstname
nature of American culture but this long
range intimacy nevertheless came as
something of a surprise I began to
wonder whether these lectures when they
were delivered by Carl Jung were
affectionately known as the Charlie
lectures to be changed later when a
speaker was Margaret Mead of course to
the Maggie lectures anyway I feel that
something is demanded of me in return
for this spontaneous show of geniality
so I insist that while I'm here in Yale
I should not be known as professor
Eagleton but as dr. Eagleton
let no one claim that we brits don't
know how to unbend my delight in this
informality was tempered rather quickly
as I read on in the lecture in a letter
to discover that the Terry lectures were
traditionally devoted to two subjects
I know embarrassingly little about
namely science and religion I have
however never allowed ignorance to deter
me from anything which is why I stand
before you today though I must confess
that I did begin my intellectual career
as an incurably amateur species of
theologian in those heady post-american
two days when in which anyone able to
pronounce kilobits or to wonder aloud
whether Coke and hotdogs might do just
as well for the Eucharist was instantly
drafted onto the editorial board of some
opaque journal
based in Nijmegen all I can claim in
this respect alas is that what I think I
may know just about enough theology to
be able to spot when someone like
Richard Dawkins or Christopher Hitchens
a couplet i shall henceforth reduce for
convenience to the solitary signifier
Dickens is talking out of the back of
his neck I should also add that the only
kind of theology I don't know much about
is Christian theology I mean I don't
know anything about any other theology
the only kind of theology I don't know
much about is Cristin ecology and
therefore I shall confine my discussions
in these lectures to that much as I
dislike speakers who go on interminably
about their personal experience in their
large capital letters a personal word is
scarcely avoidable here I was brought up
as a conventional Roman Catholic family
of Irish provenance in working-class
England and imbibed in my childhood a
set of baroque and hermetic doctrines
which sorry was astonished to discover
later were supposed to have some sort of
bearing on human existence this had
never occurred to me for a moment the
age of eight or whatever it was rather
like being brought up in a strictly
observant Marxist family learning at one
parents knee for example about the you
know transformation of quantity into the
quality or the negation of the negation
without a clue that all this was
supposed to have something to do with
questions of human freedom and justice
since the ideas I was taught as a child
seemed to me as I approached student age
to illuminate human existence about as
profoundly as the croakings of a frog it
seemed natural when I arrived at
university to discard this whole way of
talking for some something have rather
more relevance and humanity in the
cambridge of the early 1960s this was
known among other things as
existentialism a term which for the most
part was an ontological imposing way of
saying that one was only 19 far from
home feeling rather blue
and rather like a toddler in a playgroup
didn't have a clue what was going on
around you a few decades later this
condition persisted among late
adolescence but it was now known as per
structuralism but there was also
socialism which I'd imbibed or learnt at
my parents knee my father's knee
certainly along with Irish republicanism
and which seemed to touch more relevant
to the human species than the doctrine
of say limbo a spiritual condition not
to be confused with a Caribbean dance or
recalling the Latin name for the precise
type of worship appropriate to the
Virgin Mary as opposed to the brand of
worship proper to those truly
bureaucratic subcommittees known as
Saints things however didn't prove quite
so simple so no sooner had I arrived in
Cambridge at an age where any reasonably
sensitive moderately perceptive person
would have rejected for the nonsense it
largely was what I'd learnt at school
then the Second Vatican Council broke
out along with a version of the
Christian gospel which seemed to me to
make some rather more urgent human and
political sense which cost you something
to turn down I mean you might turn it
down but you couldn't just turn it down
on the cheap like so many versions of
Christianity the rethink this needless
to say brought its own frustrations I
mean the rethinking that this seemed to
entail look like involving a lot of
tedious spade work as the character in
PG Woodhouse remarks when his
interlocutor seems not to understand the
word Pig for it is of course always
easier to buy one's rejection of a
belief system as I say on the cheap for
example by dismissing out of hand a
version of Christianity that only
seriously weird types you know some of
them lurking sheepishly in caves on the
edges of towns too ashamed to come out
would espouse in the first place it's
easier to believe that Nietzsche was a
forerunner of fascism than to grasp that
he was a precursor of Foucault or to
write off Marxism on the grounds that it
dreams of a world relieved of inequities
in which
men and women will all be spiritually
Richard and materially miserable in
exactly the same way the so-called new
theology I stumbled on at the age of 18
or so with the aid of a few maverick
Dominicans and rather more pints of
bitter was none of course new at all it
was only new to likes of callow young
Papists like myself it saw God the
Creator not as some kind of mega
manufacturer or cosmic chief executive
officer as the Richard Dawkins school of
nineteenth-century
liberal rationalism tends to imagine
what the theologian have a mccabe calls
the idolatrous notion of god as a very
large and powerful creature dawkins were
wrongly considers more of this in a
future lecture by larry don't talk is
wrongly considers the Christianity
offers a rival view of the universe to
science and is thus rather like someone
who thinks that a novel is a botched
piece of sociology that who therefore
can't really see the point of it at all
why read Thomas Mann when you can read
Max Weber he makes an error of genre or
category mistake without the kind of
thing Christian belief is and imagines
then that the only alternative to this
is dispensing that faith from the need
for evidence altogether the New
Testament has of course almost nothing
to say about God the Creator for
Christian theology God is not a mega
manufacturer but rather what sustains
all things in being by his love and who
would still be this even if the world
had no beginning which perhaps it didn't
he's the reason why there's something
rather than nothing the condition of
possibility of any entity whatsoever but
he's not himself to be reckoned up
beside those entities anymore that it
makes much sense to make account of
tables chairs and acts of mercy true to
Judaic iconoclasm we forbidden to make
graven images of this nonentity because
the only image of him is us is
and women God the there is a document
that records this God's eternal
dispiriting struggle with organized
religion known as the Bible God the
Creator is not a manufacturer but an
artist indeed not only an artist but an
East eat moreover who made the world
with no functional end in view but
simply for the love and delight of it or
as we might say in more theological
language for the hell of it as indeed a
quick look around the world will confirm
quite rapidly made it made it as gift
superfluity and gratuitous gesture made
it out of nothing than rather out of
some grim necessity the world thus
belongs the theology as I understand it
to that exceedingly rare class of
objects which in a way that would have
delighted the heart of Oscar Wilde exist
entirely for their own sake and for no
really utilitarian end a category which
along with God includes
art at least the way it's been defined
since the 18th century evil and humanity
as far as evil goes you'll be able to
read my thoughts on that in a remarkably
cheap and extraordinarily attractive
book that I'm publishing next year
called an essay on evil it's part of the
world sharing in God's own freedom that
the world works all by itself its
autonomous as God is it's part of its
belonging to God
those autonomous and therefore the
science is possible science is made
possible by that God in short is every
bit as gloriously pointless as Dickens
tells us he is on that at least Dickens
is absolutely right he is if you like a
kind of perpetual critique of
instrumental reason if we are God's
creatures it's in the first place
because like him we exist or should
exist purely for the jouissance of it
Jesus unlike most Americans as I
understand it does no work he's accused
of being the glutton and a drunkard he
doesn't go to bed at 9:00 o'clock and
get up at 5:30 and he respects the
Sabbath not because it means going to
church but of course because it means a
release temporary escape from the curse
of Labor are the best reasons for being
Christian as for being a socialist is
that you don't like to do any work you
reject that fearful idolatry of Labor so
rife in nations like this one I see
coming among you to criticize you by the
way as a kind of liberal interventionism
as you might the doctrine that the world
is made out of nothing
is meant to alert us of course not to
some enormous manufacturing ingenuity on
the part of its creator but to the
mind-blowing contingency of the cosmos
to the astonishing fact that it might
just as well never have happened the
fact that like a modernist work of art
its existence is entirely unfounded and
that like such an artwork it's
perpetually hollowed out and
overshadowed by this sublime negativity
by the haunted by the possibility that
it might never have existed at all all
this to be sure is not to deny for a
moment that instrumental reason has its
place there would for example be no
immense of pay triple ethics without it
these petitions are seized by the beauty
and sensuous particularity of things
theologians by the fact that their
existence is mind-blowingly contingent
while scientists have to press these
things into the knowledge and service of
humankind and so can't afford to spend
all their time emitting grunts of
pleasure or shouts of astonishment this
self delighting energy known as divinity
which is entirely without point or
function which stands in no need of
justification before some grim-faced
tribunal of utility or duty or diced or
production or history or teleology there
fullness of life is of course what we
know under another description as
morality let us say basically having a
good time morality meaning of course
having a good time in contrast with the
Kantian view but if it feels nice then
it can't be good I admittedly
simplifying the critique of practical
reason a little here but may have
noticed but nevertheless the point might
stand the morality Jesus preaches is a
reckless extravagant improvident
over-the-top a scandal to utility and a
stumbling block to real estate agents
give away your coked as well as your
cloak turn the other cheek love those
who insult you walk the extra mile this
is probably of course because he thought
at the end of the world was just around
the corner which turns out to have been
rather a grave miscalculation Jesus his
sense of history was a little awry in
any case it's not the kind of morality
one associates with chartered
accountants or oil executives because
God is transcendent that that's to say
because he doesn't need humanity and
made us just for the hell of it he's not
neurotically possessive others but he's
able to let us be and the word for this
is freedom which is where of course for
Christian theology as I understand it we
belong to him
most deeply he is the ground of our
freedom and not the obstacle to it it's
our dependence on him but allows us to
be self-determining as it's our
dependence on language or history or
culture or other people which allows us
to come into our own this non God or
anti God who hates burnt offerings and
acts of pious self-righteousness tells
us that he's the enemy of idols fetishes
and graven images of all kinds gods
churches burnt offerings the Stars and
Stripes nations sexuality ideologies
you should know him for what he is when
you see the Hungary being filled with
good things and the rich being sent
empty away salvation rather pathetically
turns out not matter of cult and law and
ritual of special observances and
conforming to a moral law or even of
being splendidly virtuous but a question
of feeding the hungry welcoming the
immigrants protecting the poor from the
violence of the rich astonishingly were
saved according to this theology not by
a special apparatus known as religion
but by the quality of our everyday
relations with each other as Charles
Taylor has pointed out Christianity not
the French intelligentsia invented the
concept of everyday life and it's all
very every day there's nothing heroic
about the New Testament at all Jesus is
a sick joke of a messiah messiahs are
not born in stables they don't enter the
national capital riding on a donkey and
they don't get themselves strung up
either Christianity is all rather
disappointingly quotidian materialist
unglamorous and prosaic from the
viewpoint of Jewish tradition a murdered
Messiah is an absolute outrage as much a
contradiction in terms as military
intelligence or Alabama ode cuisine
the whole cumbersome paraphernalia of
religion is to be replaced by another
kind of temple that of the murdered and
transfigured body of Jesus and this body
is dedicated in particular to the
outrage of the zealots and the Pharisees
and the Republican right wing of all
ages is dedicated in particular to those
losers deadbeats riffraff and colonial
collaborators who are not righteous but
flamboyantly unrighteous who live either
in chronic transgression of the Mosaic
law or who as Gentiles fall outside it
these men and women are not being asked
to bargain their way into God's favor by
being remarkably respectable and well
behaved scandalously we're told that God
loves them anyway in all of their
wickedness and Unruh generous II and
it's this which unlocks that lethal
deadlock of the law and desire which
Lacan calls the real the answer to the
death drive to what seriously
arrived as the death Drive greed for
self-destruction is love love is the
answer to the real as it were Jesus's
message is that he's on the side of
these people despite their viciousness
that the source that that source of
erotic exuberant humorous self
delighting inexhaustible life that he
calls his father is neither judge
patriarch accuser or super-ego which is
of course the satanic image of God the
God that we so much need who's going to
punishes God as Satan or adversary but
lover friend
comrade fellow accused and counsel for
the defense and that they have been
called upon to do absolutely nothing
other than acknowledge this fact in that
love act of loving ascent which is known
as faith His mercy and forgiveness are
ruthlessly unforgiving powers which
break violently into our protective
self-rationalizing little spheres
mashing are sentimental delusions and
turning our world brutally upside down
in Jesus the law is revealed to have
been all along the law of love and mercy
which we find terrifying
to accept so we insist that it's not
that at all but a kind of super-ego and
God is disclosed not as some Blake Ian
nobodaddy but as a helpless and
vulnerable animal the flayed and bloody
scapegoat of Calvary which is now the
true signifier of the law which is to
say in other words those who are
faithful to the law of justice and
comradeship will be done away with by
the state as heaven cave literally puts
it if you don't love you're dead and if
you do they'll kill you here then is
your pie-in-the-sky your opium of the
people your rosy cheeked consolation
your sweet illusions here is the fantasy
and escapism that the hard-headed
secularists pragmatists find so
distasteful Freud so religion as a
mitigation of a harshness of a human
condition but she will surely be at
least as plausible to claim that what we
call reality is a mitigation of the new
testaments ruthless demands which
include such agreeable acts of escapism
as being ready to lay down your life for
a complete stranger imitating Jesus
means of course imitating his death not
just his life since the former is the
consummation of the latter the only
authentic image of this violently loving
remorselessly accepting God is a
tortured reviled and executed political
criminal who dies in an act of
solidarity with the so called anawim the
poor outcasts destitute and dispossessed
in poor line phrase the earth the scum
and refuse of society who will form the
current the cornerstone of the new
regime known as the kingdom of God and
of whom Jesus himself is the
representative Jesus's death and descent
into hell is
voyage into madness cruelty terror and
absurdity since only a revolution that
cuts that deep can answer to our dismal
condition it might incidentally be
enough to respond to those who claim not
to believe in original sin to ask them
whether they've been reading the
newspapers we aren't speaking here of a
cautiously reformist affair of pouring
new wine into old bottles but of an
avant-gardist epiphany of the utterly
and absolutely new of a regime so
thoroughly revolutionary as to surpass
all image and utterance a regime
arraigned of justice and fellowship
which even now is striking into the this
bankrupt day pass a washed-up world no
liberal ground is given to us here is
available to us here the choice between
justice and what cynjohn calls the
powers of this world the powers of the
Pentagon of the White House of number 10
Downing Street and so on is absolute and
stark a matter of fundamental conflict
and antithesis of a cutting sword not of
peace consensus middle grounds and
negotiations given the lamentable state
of humanity I mean the prevalence of
greed idolatry delusion the depth of our
instinct to dominate and possess the
dull persistence of injustice and
exploitation the chronic anxiety which
leads us to hate and maim the sickness
suffering and despair which Jesus seems
to associate with evil given all this
the advent of this unashamed utopia
doesn't come at all easily it comes only
through a turbulent passage through
death nothingness and dispossession the
passage in classical tragic mode of the
reviled and polluted thing from weakness
to power from death to life for which I
suppose the ancient name is not so much
tragedy as sacrifice sacrifice as the
turbulent passage
of the reviled and polluted thing from
life to death
from weakness to power only by an
uncompromising readiness to abandon our
dished up world altogether rather than
that most Algie neuroses we know as
conservatism can we live in the faith
and hope that a more authentic life will
struggle out somewhere on the other side
of this radical self divestment so that
the stumbling block can become
ultimately the cornerstone only through
such an openness to our own finitude and
frailty and mortality only by preserving
the kind of steadfast fidelity to
failure which is scandalous to nations
like this one which despise a loser I
think the sky's limit you know yes you
can yes we can yes we can what by the
way only through that surely for that
fidelity that meant maintaining that
fidelity to failure can any human power
prove durable only through this
impossible stonily disenchanted realism
staring the Medusa's head of the
monstrous traumatic obscene reel of the
crucifixion full in the face can any
sort of resurrection be possible only by
accepting this as the very last word
seeing everything else as so much
sentimentalist garbage I'd logical
illusion false utopia bogus consolation
ludicrously upbeat idealism only then
may perhaps not prove to be quite the
last word after all the New Testament is
a brutal destroyer of human illusions if
you follow Jesus and you don't end up
dead it appears you have some explaining
to do far from fostering some morbid
cult of suffering Jesus seems to regard
suffering as unequivocally a form of
evil and opposes to it what he calls
abundance of life
which is to say what the gospel calls
eternal life life at its most fully and
richly human intoxicated with its own
high spirits and self delight Jesus is
of course remarkably laid-back about
sexuality as well unlike those millions
of his disciples who can talk or think
of hardly anything else and who
therefore have that much in common with
the pornographers they run out of town
in fact there's hardly anything about
sexuality in the New Testament at all we
should no doubt one reason why the
Gospels aren't taught on cultural
studies courses
it's just not that important sin Thomas
Aquinas claims have so distorted our
emotional natures that we're unable to
enjoy sex as we should
if by sin or means as I suppose Paul
means by the sins of the flesh which of
course has nothing to do with a supposed
badness of the body violence aggression
Envy acquisitiveness possessiveness and
so on then that these damage are
creaturely and effective life can
scarcely be denied and Aquinas despite
perhaps not doing that much about sex at
first hand well
so we presume is absolutely right it's
also worth adding that Jesus's attitude
to the family is of course one of
consistent and sometimes virulent
hostility he has come to break up those
cozy little conservative settlements so
beloved of American advertisers in the
name of his mission which will set one
member of a family against another and
he seems to have precious little time
for his own family in particular now I
wouldn't want to label this sort of
account Liberation Theology
all authentic theology is liberation
theology nor am i necessarily pressing
upon it upon you was true for the good
reason that it might not be although I
should add that holding these views is
an excellent strategy that anyone
wishing to get rid of all their friends
and colleagues at a stroke provoked ins
as they do irritation from the secular
left and outrage from the religious
right less when Christians are in dire
need of dating agencies
but though this account may not be true
it is not in my view stupid vicious or
absurd to this extent I believe it's
worth speaking up for against those like
Dickens who in a fine equipoise of
arrogance and ignorance assert that all
religious view belief is exactly of that
kind namely stupid and so on I don't
have a imagine for a moment that ditch
khun's will be much impressed by this
account since for one thing it's
scarcely the conventional wisdom of
North Oxford or Washington DC it
represents a version of humanity which
is far more radical and ruthless than
anything that Richard Dawkins would
countenance with his eminently suburban
smugly sanguine trust in the efficacy of
a spot of social engineering here and a
dash of liberal enlightenment there the
view of the world I've just tried to lay
out is not what one characteristically
hears around North Oxford dinner tables
or in the fleshpots of the American
capital perhaps I should add that when
Christopher Hitchens were still a humble
Kris he and I being comrades comrades in
the same far left political outfit used
to leaflet a car factory in Oxford
together but he has gone on to higher
things discovering in the process a
degree of political maturity as a
naturalized citizen of Babylon whereas I
have remained stuck in the same old
political groove a case of Arrested
Development if ever there was one the
antagonism between Dickens and those
like myself in other words it's quite as
much political as it is theological I
where Richard Dawkins and I differ most
fundamentally I suspect is not on the
question of God science superstition
evolution or the origins of the universe
theologians are not in the least
interested Quay theologians in say
whether a process of as crude and
blundering as evolution could have
produced something as exquisitely
complex as Henry James
you're supposed to laugh with that but
it doesn't matter I I kept my travel
expenses in any case so it's I don't
want you to feel bad or embarrassed in
the difference between science and
theology as I understand it or at least
one of them is is over whether you see
the world as a gift or not and one can't
resolve that difference just by
inspecting the thing anymore the new
conduce from looking at a porcelain vars
that it's a birthday present the
difference between Dickens and radicals
like myself also hinges on whether you
accept that the ultimate signifier of
the human condition is the tortured and
murdered body of a political criminal
and what the implications of this are
for living are we saying in a future
lecture that faith nichkhun seems not to
realize isn't of course in the first
place at least in that something or
somebody exists what I'll be calling the
the Yeti theory of faith are they out
there or not and if so are they coming
to get us or do they have a superb
indifference to us you know but of
course a matter of commitment and
Allegiance faith is not is something
which might make a difference the
frightful situation you find yourself in
as is the case say with faith faith in
fascism or socialism it isn't the first
place a matter of signing up to a
description of reality it's in the first
place performative rather than
propositional it is as I understand it
not primarily a matter of signing on for
the proposition that there exists
somewhere a Supreme Being but the kind
of commitment made manifest by a human
being at the end of his tether
foundering in darkness pain and
bewilderment who nevertheless remains
faithful to the promise of a
mysteriously transformative love who
somehow impossibly manages still to
believe that that in the end is the
ultimate reality despite all appearances
to the contrary trouble with the
Dawkins's of this world however is they
don't find themselves in a frightful
situation at all well oxford high table
is a pretty frightful situation as I
have reasons no but on the whole they
don't find themselves in that situation
other than the fact that there are for
them a lot of deranged men and women
around called religious believers which
they find fairly frightful I'm so
naturally they have no use for such
embarrassingly old-fashioned language as
depravity and redemption even after
Auschwitz it would seem there's nothing
for them to be redeemed things are just
that not dead just not that desperate
enough and in their view it's simply
shoddy and self-indulgent leftist
rhetoric to imagine that they are your
average liberal rationalist doesn't need
to believe that despite the tormented
condition of humanity there might still
implausibly enough be hope since he
doesn't believe in such torment in the
first place this is one important reason
I think why God's talk makes no sense to
people like nichkhun's
though it's by no means the only reason
Dickens has many excellent reasons as
I'll be saying later not to believe in
God and to see religion as an atrocious
phenomenon plenty of people repudiate
God for interesting reasons but as far
as this point and this point alone goes
Dickens rejects him for reasons which
are both boring and politically
disreputable as the first truly global
mass movement in history
Christianity contemplates as I
understand it a condition of justice
fellowship and self fulfillment far
beyond anything that might normally be
thought either possible or even
desirable on new college oxford high
table it's equally hard to imagine you
know telling some political lobbyists in
Washington that only through a tragic
process of loss nothingness and self
dispossession can humanity come into its
own cycle half the bar and call for help
in such civilized circles God is God
is not really anymore acceptable and say
talk about socialism neither language
gain fits at all smoothly into the
hard-nosed ethos of contemporary
capitalism when Christopher Hitchens
writes in a recent review of liberation
as I quote a sorry liberation theology
as a sorry affair I take it he's
referring to the liberation quite as
much as to the theology although in the
so called Santa Fe document of 1980 the
United States government denounce such
theology as a subversive threat long
gathers from Daniel Dennett's rather
disappointing the conventional critique
of religion breaking the spell but he
thinks that the invasion of Iraq was
fine if it could have been better
managed which is enough to suggest that
not every swinging atheist iconoclast is
a radical in any other sense whatsoever
the advanced capitalist system is
inherently and naturally atheistic I
mean godless in its actual material
practices don't look at what it says
look at what it does and in the values
and beliefs inherent in those practices
whatever some of its apologists may
piously over its atheistic in all the
wrong ways whereas one might claim that
Marx and Nietzsche were atheistic in
mostly the right ways a society of
packaged fulfilment administered desire
managed politics and consumers economics
is unlikely to cut to the kind of depth
where theological questions are even
properly reasonable just as it rules out
political and moral questions of a
certainly profanity I mean what on earth
would I just lost my page there on earth
would suspense is unbearable
for me as well I can't remember what I
was going to say it must be here
somewhere
I just knit back to my hotel actually
and if you don't mind yes yes what on
earth will be the point of God in such a
center theater some divine hand took
that page from me well what in that kind
of setup would be the point of God other
than as ideological legitimation of
inherently non spiritual practices
spiritual nostalgia or a sort of means
of private extrication from the world
taken to be increasingly values the
other place where here I will end and we
could have a discussion of this the
other place where so-called spiritual
values driven from the face of a
brutally pragmatic capitalism that
really has no place for them the other
place where they've taken up a kind of
uneasy refuge is in I suppose sort of
new ageism which is I think very
interesting precisely the kind of cult
of spirit that one would expect a
materialist society a very hard-headed
society to produce as its own antithesis
you know the only shoddy version of the
spiritual that a material society could
muster that incidentally I think is
exactly what Marx had in mind when he
wrote famously that religion we all know
about the opium of the people of course
before that he says something much more
complimentary about it he says it's the
heart of a heartless world it's the soul
of soulless conditions it is the opium
of the people meaning I think that
conventional religion as he knew it was
just the kind of disembodied and
infinite impotently sentimental sort of
understanding of the spiritual that one
would expect from a hard-headed
heartless and soulless society
romanticism is the flipside of
utilitarianism as indeed Marx himself
comments so it is today that those who
are in every other sense worldly cynical
and hard-bitten know Hollywood
superstars for example and reveal
when it comes to spirituality a truly
bottomless credulity nobody is more
otherworldly than the worldly no nobody
more soft centered than the hard-nosed
spiritual matters for these people must
naturally be as remote from their
lawyers and agents and minders and
drivers as possible in order to provide
some sort of fantasy alternative to them
this is why people who are in every
other respect mundane and streetwise
believe that Affairs on earth are being
controlled by a spaceship hidden behind
a cloud they wouldn't believe that if
they only had $38 in the bank
one thinks for example of obviously the
case of Madonna and Kabbalah I won't go
into that except to confess and I hope
this won't go beyond these four walls
that I did once actually many years ago
sleep in Madonna's bed she wasn't in it
herself anybody who wishes to approach
me and find out the rest that story for
a very small and in considerable fee
please do so after this lecture is over
in other words money is a great breeder
of unreality is a great germinator
of fantasy as marx so brilliantly sees
it's not at all materialistic and I'm
sort of prosaic it's something
extraordinarily exotic and extravagant
the idea that spirituality is about
visiting the sick or fighting injustice
would no doubt strike these cab lists
and necromancer's and chiropractors of
the psyche as intolerably trivial I have
I'm afraid not even got on to
Christianity foul which was by far the
most interesting bit of my lecture
remember it was supposed to be about
Christianity fair and foul for those of
you who bothered to read the poster but
I think alas I will have to stop there
will be a great deal of foul nasaan
thirsty I can assure you at the lecture
but now I think we have some time for
discussion